so on wednesday coinbase's share price
recovered from 322 to 341 is now only
down five percent off of tuesday's peak
drop it represents a 72 billion dollar
market cap for the company which is
extraordinary in q3 coinbase saw large
quarter over quarter drops in major
categories like revenue users and
profits
not dissimilar to robinhood story but in
their year-over-year numbers they were
still up huge so if you remember robin
hood's earnings on episode 1313 two
weeks ago revenue was down 35 quarter of
a quarter but up 35 year over year
what that means what that says to me is
there was just a you know we had a big
quarter people with stemi checks
you know crypto booms everybody in a
mania to buy tulips or
the next
you know giant wave of consumer and
technology innovation
time will tell
transaction based revenues will swing
wildly depending on market conditions
that that's the truth about these things
if things get really popular and there
is a mania whether it is you know amc
stock and stonks or dogecoin or bitcoin
or nfts you know things can go crazy
although i don't know if coinbase is
actually trading in nfts yet so let's
just get into the earnings real quick
total revenue 1.3 billion that's up four
times year over year 4x year over year
that is extraordinary we've been talking
about high growth companies being 20 30
40 50 growth 4x 400 growth it's down 40
quarter of a quarter there's going to be
bumps in the road in these high growth
companies
so i think that's to be expected
transaction revenue a billion uh that's
83 percent of the total revenue again
that's up 4x year over year down 45
percent quarter of a quarter
subscription revenue and services uh
revenue 145 million that's about 11
this is mostly made up of blockchain
rewards from people staking ethereum and
custodial fees of 31.5 million that's
where you get they get paid to hold on
to your crypto and make sure it doesn't
get stolen subscription revenue grew
from 600k in 2020 to 8.6 million in
2021. those are small numbers compared
to the transaction fees the custodial
fees etc however it's 12x right 13x like
that's a big multiple and so i do think
that robinhood and coinbase and all
these financial services companies are
going to have great subscription revenue
if people will pay for com in netflix
and spotify and steezy to learn how to
dance to learn how to you know get to
bed easier they're going to pay for
financial subscriptions it's still worth
it right and so i'm paying for twitter
now i did twitter blue for 2.99 a month
other revenue 77 million uh they don't
specify what this is um i'm thinking
those are services revenues when they do
big block transactions i.e
you know if somebody wants to buy a
billion dollars in bitcoin maybe that's
what it is last week crypto news outlet
the block reported coinbase was testing
a new subscription service called
coinbase one benefits would reportedly
include no fee trading uh which would
put them head-to-head with robinhood
which is going head-to-head with them in
crypto now and prioritize phone support
on holidays and weekends no word on the
cost of the subscription yet i think
five ten bucks a month is a no-brainer i
would like to see these companies even
go fifteen twenty dollars per month and
have something really great for people
coinbase is trying to diversify away
from transaction-based revenue uh
according to sources robin hood offers
something similar with robinhood gold
that's five bucks a month and that lets
you have bigger instant deposits
professional research from morningstar
level two market data from nasdaq uh
access to margin investing all kinds of
like premium stuff and uh
when you have those kind of programs it
basically lets you segment who are your
best customers it's kind of the amazon
prime of uh this service you also see
that with icloud i now pay for some
icloud i pay like 30 or 40 bucks a month
for an icloud bundled subscription which
gives me arcade news two or four
terabytes for my family so now all three
of my daughters when they come to me for
a game i say go to the arcade tab you
can have any game in arcade you cannot
have the other games
because they have all kinds of upselling
and garbage in them that i hate thank
you shout out tim cook for making a nice
clean uh arcade where i can have my kids
and trust that the games are not trying
to manipulate them so much and then the
news product is pretty good too on apple
news shout out to apple news because now
i don't have to have a wall street
journal subscription i can just see some
stuff there okay back to coinbase
monthly transacting user 7.4 million
again
up massively 3.5x year over year but
down quarter of a quarter that's a good
number to uh look at like
because you do have a lot of holders you
have people who created accounts maybe
bought one bitcoin or a tenth of a
bitcoin robin hood has 17 million
monthly users so you're seeing the
difference between the crypto and the
trading of stocks i think the crypto
people
they may buy every couple of months but
they're holding it they're not selling
their bitcoin that's the whole point is
to hold it forever and so i think that's
a great opportunity for robinhood to add
users and then adding stocks is
something that coinbase could do if you
know people are trading stocks they
could get more trading going on net
income 406 million up 5x year over year
pretty efficient company down 75 percent
quarter of a quarter for these companies
i really don't care about their profits
i care about their growth and the number
of customers they have i would rather
see them not have profits at this point
and see growth public markets might feel
differently in related news bitcoin and
ethereum are now at all-time highs
between 68 thousand dollars durian
almost five
uh coinbase went public via direct
listing in april at 381 dollars a share
popped up to 421. they hit 100 billion
in july the stock bottomed out at almost
half 221 so this has been a lot of
swings we saw that also with uber which
i think during the pandemic went down to
15 16 a share up to 60 now with 45 with
price targets of 70. like these stocks
when they first come out i think wall
street has to understand the business
and look for consistency look for
profits
and so
that represents an opportunity it also
represents the danger of some of these
companies because
you know
some retail investors might not know the
difference between nicola and tesla even
though they are the first and last names
of a famous scientist they're two
radically different companies and so
people have to you know the markets i
think retail investors have to learn the
difference between them they're getting
pretty savvy i think and they have to
understand what exactly they're buying
and what the risks are you're going to
see a lot of speculative stuff come out
vtols
electric trucks anything that's a theme
quantum computing
and space travel
all of these things are highly
speculative uh synthetic biology when
these things spack and go out early
pre-revenue or modest revenue customer
traction be careful you're making a
venture style investing and if the stock
goes parabolic and goes nuts
and the company doesn't have customers
yet man just pump the brakes and you
know you can wait to buy it is my best
advice i don't want to give stock buying
advice but if my mom or my brother were
asking me and they said hey
you know do i need to buy the stock i
was like
you know it's got the same price as
another company with real revenue like
coinbase and robinhood have real
customers in revenue and nicola and
maybe this veto company maybe they don't
have customers or revenue yet maybe put
80 into the company with the customers
and 20 into the speculative one there's
some
reasonable betting strategy here and it
is gambling when you are investing in
pre-product market fit companies you are
gambling uh coinbase and robin hood are
not that these are millions of customers
loving and using these so what i'll say
about this pair of companies i obviously
have an interested one and not the other
but i have accounts on both is they're
incredibly well-run companies
they have an incredibly large user base
already and passionate users who are not
going anywhere in my estimation so i am
a huge fan of both coinbase and robin
hood also if you look at coinbase and
robinhood uh the founders are still
running the companies and that's always
a great sign and they're constantly if
you look at the product velocity
releasing new products so robinhood with
their crypto wallet and nfts are coming
to coinbase according to some
announcements so
product velocity is really really
powerful in a company led by a founder
you see that with elon starr with travis
just constantly releasing new products
uh you start with steve jobs there's
this obsession with new groundbreaking
um
investments in
new products and so congratulations to
the coinbase team okay next up is our
ten items for our startup checklist
we're gonna go over markets and branding
stick with us